[Music]
latest trend news submitted by jisu a or
Joyce ooh yeah yeah a food safety expert
is warning against the latest raw water
trend of what's Ono unfiltered untreated
yeah yeah it does not taste like what is
just tap water it does taste like ass
it's gross but tastes really good
Kirkland whatever good Kirkland cold
tastes good yeah
everyone's got different taste buds on
the beginning I like smart water
I don't like Carl head like especially
in room temperature for one as cold as
more bearable I'm parched
I'd rather pour it on the ground
searched I wouldn't even feed my plants
Arrowhead that's what I said just
signing sign that do you think I could I
could deal with this on you you know why
because the sunny hasani's made at the
coke Factory
so all of them pipes be clogged I used
to work for water why I used to work out
a lot of company right so we used to do
that pH check for all the water bottles
Hasani has one of the highest the pH
balance is off is the nightgood that's
why you probably taste the ICD yeah it's
gross and then every time I open I'm
like why is it sound like I'm opening
soda there's no regulation for like what
bottling water at the like the soda
Factory but they're like there is for
tap water
so sometimes tap water pH is more better
we just have that thing at the house
where we have that old Korean actually
come in and he attached the water filter
oh yeah yeah that water taste good you
got like four mineral tanks and it goes
through its bomb yo we had all those
expired for two years it still tastes
something [ __ ] old people should talk
about water filter
but that is my line but straight up
though I don't that's why we don't need
this no more you just get that little
high just you to come the Chinese I just
you know or whatever if he comes in she
doesn't did
what's the raw water like drink it from
a waterfall drink pretty much drinking
from spring I said you got my mom all
the time
you don't Eaton Canyon we used to hide
that as a kid I know it I didn't know I
didn't know I was at all fresh water I
mean my mom we [ __ ] drinking the [ __ ]
why won't your mom be doing that your
mom knows that I know but I think we
just thought it was like natural and
then like [ __ ] six feet away there's
like a [ __ ] Mexican family [ __ ]
taking a piss I know we didn't know but
do you see what happens like the general
rule is if you're lost on the [ __ ]
wild
if the water is still let it be if it
flows you can drink it I think were
gonna make something right I thought I
thought I was going to but I didn't have
anything you're a horrible battle rapper
yeah
listen when the water [ __ ] just drink it
yeah so if it's usually like it's
running water or something like that so
the smart thing for you to have done is
to go to the waterfall and drink the
wine what's going though it was going
you still taste like it tastes it fresh
like piss Mike is like untreated
unfiltered water like you could have you
can get eco like hunter-gatherers are
like just people that are living in the
wild they can drink the water straight
up or do they boil it see I don't know
they're maybe their body got the right
things to just kind of like battle that
[ __ ] it's supposed to be like running
water supposed to be I'm sure they can
look at it too and just be like not safe
you know people right now this trend is
like hitting huge especially in Silicon
Valley where they're buying 2.5 gallon
jugs for 60 bucks
god damn treated water like [ __ ] that
[ __ ] dude I need that [ __ ] to be
filtered through a four tanks no then
there are people that actually go and
they like hunt for like natural spring
water and then they'll bring back water
to their homes and like they only use
that water I think those people need to
do that though are they like the same
kind
constant like these are the same people
that are anti-vaccination yeah yeah yeah
they need it
I know these type of people are they
fair-skinned Mart they how we say Oh
American why yeah American flight oh by
the way I I do realize that there's a
little bit of confusion that spilled
onto my channel when we say white we're
not talking about UK we're not talking
about Europe we're come on white America
to the group that we knew and grew up
around which is California white
Americans because country white people
don't do stupid things like this yeah
but I don't know cuz they're Asian
actually yeah actually course they would
look like that
long hair it's that it's that West Coast
hippie like New Age Tom's wanted
[ __ ] yeah he looks like he
smells like sweat and body oils yeah
and they typically do like yoga oh but
chewy it's like this [ __ ] what's the
called I think they put in dreads and
[ __ ] they put it all over it's like
their perfume yeah you've probably
smelled it I'm sure anywhere a Mexican
shop smells [ __ ] incense that's where
you find that what you need you've
smelled it you know my grandparents are
so ghetto cuz they grew up in like an
awesome [ __ ] war-torn country that
when they order water from like the
Taiwanese Sparkletts they still don't
trust that [ __ ] and have to boil every
single part of it but they're just so
used to boiling water that even when it
comes in like a legit company now from a
truck they're like now he's about
boiling the water you want that because
they're saying that they don't want to
kill the germs they're saying that this
water is alive this is life
so you're the water that with the water
that we drink it's dead yeah pretty much
is dead water
give me viruses cuz it's living inside
me like a fart in the mouth of they
wanna live air yeah it's like the water
that they're getting shipped to their
homes like some people get like tons of
Watership they're like you know this
water only lasts like about a month and
then after a month it starts turning
green that's how you know that the water
is alive people more alive I've never
add water turn green oh that's because
George because our bacteria yeah oh yeah
there's no algae so basically algae
thrives in healthy water so it's it's a
good sign when you do see algae like I
used to get it like when I used to [ __ ]
with my fish tank and stuff
like we don't want it we want to scrub
it off and all that did you drink the
water no hell nos nest that's an ass you
know what they should do you should get
live water from Tijuana I heard it's
really good
and I heard that after three weeks you
actually lose a lot of weight I don't
know why thank you boil it you know I'm
sick instead its life its life and for
some you lose weight for some reason its
soul is like no matter what you eat you
just keep losing weight it's amazing
well what other water has algae the
water of my hot tub with all our dead
skin cells I have to put chlorine in it
every week or also get algae I guess I
get the closet but we have to be
drinking that kind of stuff since we
were babies where we have the you know
everything in our system that can battle
out the bad shits I mean other than the
water being alive like do they also say
that there's minerals in there too
that's beneficial
I have minerals in my water the minerals
are dead though that's why we have
minerals in our Kirkley and water and
all that but that's for taste yeah and
they're also these are the same people
that are saying that floor or maybe not
the same people some of these people are
saying that fluoride in your tap water
is like a mind controlling drug oh
that's why they will not drink tap water
if you have to have like live straight
from the source type of water so this is
like one company a different company
called tourmalines spring
so what's deadly about it you call I had
potato pending on where you're getting a
betta goetta
I kind of think like I'm picturing
Southern California desert nastiness
right but if I was in Hawaii where
there's plenty of rainfall and natural
things going like I feel like I'll be a
little bit safer there still could be
like animal feces in them and you never
know yeah
because there's this thing called a rat
lungworm disease that's going around and
I took a big [ __ ] gulp of water when
I was swimming in this waterfall thing
and then I went up the waterfall and I
saw this dead rat and in for the whole
week I swear to God
I'm not like a hypochondriac but I swear
I was getting parasites in my brain no I
was like no I mean that's the one case
of hypochondriac type behavior that I
did have because I started freaking out
liar you said you there's certain things
that happen you Koda like WebMD you see
you tell us that I did
yeah we've the last time I told you I
forgot we'll pay attention like that
much but like you're always like I want
to MMD and I made a mistake I think he's
the opposite of a hypochondriac though
if anything he could use a little bit
cuz this [ __ ] would have like a
knife in his stomach Eagles Hawaiian
waters healing opposite what good Disney
like when we were doing the Spartan Race
like we all got cut up because like
everything was dry and there's a lot of
rocks and everything and then as soon as
we got into the muddy waters he's like
[Laughter]
yeah but apparently it's like a really
popular thing though
will you just sell kimchi waters there's
like probiotic today oh that's right
it's alive it's a live kimchi water like
yeah why are we so stupid if we could
figure out a way to have this live water
without the dangerous things I'm down to
try it out you know I know her kombucha
no that's a probiotic water it's live
though it has live cultures yeah but
this is different because this isn't
probiotics in the water it's just like
natural stuff [ __ ] natural stuff I like
my [ __ ] manufacturers [ __ ] I think I bit
down if it was like like let's say we're
in Alaska at Antarctica where it's
frozen and there's like a little
dripping thing of water and I drink it
immediately it from there not bottled
and then now going through like hot
California freeways and then arriving
believe and then I just picture that
like you know you know there's like that
icicles dripping water and then when you
look up as a dead caveman inside snow
when I go snowboarding I just get this
put my mouth you can tell I found that
no where are our city water comes from
right the tap water that we drink it's
all the [ __ ] shower drain everything
that goes through yeah and then they go
through the whole system they separate
the poo poo in the trash from the water
they let the water just sit and bake in
the Sun for like a long time with the
algae eat that [ __ ] up and with
the remaining water then they filter
that and give it back to us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]